Oh
the songs so specially one of the video
to really have a meaning to it humble
and kind a fitting title for Tim's new
single we were behind the scenes for the
video that debuts tomorrow on his
Facebook page and it turns out Tim got a
little help from Oprah I was running on
the treadmill on morning and I saw the
belief series of Oprah's coming that was
coming on and I saw the 30-second
trailer of it and I thought that's it
that's the look that I want this video
is nothing
I made a few phone calls to a few
friends and she agreed to let us use the
footage for the video Tim's music
inspired our next country hit maker
that's Thomas Rhett getting all wet in
his new video a die a happy man has
topped Billboard's Hot Country Songs
chart for 11 weeks now
Rhett says he owes it all to the girl he
met in the first grade his wife Lauren
and that's Lauren in the video I
definitely wrote it you know with her in
mind and you know all the lyrics are
kind of about us and our marriage my
relationships baby
the video was shot while the couple was
on vacation and Hawaii but Thomas will
be in New York this summer at the Live
Nation Farnborough festival with this
guy Jason Aldean
a 38 year old country mecha star marry
27 year old former American Idol
contestant Brittney Kerr last year and
yeah expect kids she's a lot younger
than I am so she's uh you know I got to
make this happen quick I don't wanna be
the old dad